[Music]
a departed director unpaid casting crew
and an outdated premise these are just a
few of the problems that plagued what
would sadly turn out to be Kirstie
Alley's last theatrical film the actress
who died of cancer on December 5th 2022
was best known for playing bar manager
Rebecca Howe on Cheers from 1987 until
1993. Ali won two Emmy awards for the
role she also starred alongside John
Travolta in three Look Who's Talking
films and on Veronica's Closet from 1997
until 2000 earning another Emmy
nomination though she'd later appear in
some TV projects such as scream Queens
her film acting career came to an
undistinguished end her last theatrical
film 2015's accidental love was plagued
by budget issues and abandoned by
director David O Russell before its
limited release according to
Entertainment Weekly before his own
departure Russell clashed with James
Khan over Khan's character's death scene
leading to the veteran actor leaving the
movie and his heart being recast the
film originally titled nailed was
actually never even technically finished
and several key actors not including Ali
left the production because the studio
reportedly left some of the casting crew
unpaid when the movie finally made it to
theaters it was not received well
earning the approval of just eight
percent of critics and 15 of audience
members on Rotten Tomatoes Richard Roper
of the Chicago Sun Times wrote the story
behind accidental love is weirder and
definitely more interesting than the
movie itself he went on to call the
movie itself an unmitigated disaster
adding the satire is Broad and forced
and unfunny there's no Cadence to the
setups and visual punch lines and the
likable cast is hopelessly lost here's
the plot a skating food server named
Alice played by Jessica Biel is
accidentally shot in the head with a
nail gun that's your brain you know yeah
that's my brain so please stop pushing
on it the movie follows her bizarre
experiences seeking treatment and a
normal life afterward those experiences
include meeting a man with a prolapsed
colon played by Tracy Morgan and seeking
care from a reverend with a persistent
Direction played by Kurt Fuller the
film's attempted underlying message
about the lack of affordable health care
in the United States was simply buried
under crude jokes like these critic
James mottram wrote of the film it's not
hard to see why Russell washed his hands
of the unfinished cut it would have been
better left as the mysterious movie we
never saw than the half-baked one were
lumbered with now many critics also
noted that accidental love was seemingly
past its sell by date filming started in
2008 the year Barack Obama was elected
president by the time the movie was
released in 2015 the Affordable Care Act
or Obamacare as it's popularly known had
been in effect for five years the movie
was a satire of a Health Care system
that had changed drastically during
production great she has no insurance
shut it down thank you Arlene
you're an angel bilga Berry a vulture
wrote the film offers a case study in
why Cinema has largely seeded satire to
television the flip side of topicality
is a reduced shelf life and the entire
premise of accidental love has dated in
a post-obamacare America Prairie Miller
of WBAI radio in New York noted that the
film was co-written by former vice
president Al Gore's daughter Kristen
Gore based on her novel sami's Hill she
wrote of the film it comes off as a
different Inconvenient Truth the Stellar
cast wasn't enough to save the film and
neither was the onslaught of Crash jokes
the long and sad story of accidental
love should serve as a cautionary tale
for Studio Executives directors and
actors alike to choose their projects
carefully although the careers of Ali
Beale Morgan James Marston Beverly
D'Angelo Jake Gyllenhaal and many more
were not permanently tarnished by their
appearance in accidental love the film's
infamous production lives on as a a
warning of what not to do fortunately
Ali completed the Lifetime TV movie you
can't take my daughter five years after
the debacle that was accidental love if
not for the former film as well as
appearances in TV shows like flanked the
movie once known as nailed would have
been the last memory we have of a
talented versatile and accomplished
actor
[Music]